l'histoire nous tu es comme ça par
christina qui aimerait se faire relooker
j'aimerais trop de temps vous avez vous
pensé que ça prendrait autant avec moi
nous il va vous savez quoi vous vous
allez partir pendant la pub nos
stylistes vont vous relooker vous allez
revenir vous ne vous verrez pas et on
mettra un miroir comme ça et vous verrez
ce que ça donne à les porter
avec du coeur des jupes erdan option
voip
on a en bois dit gilles verdez et
isabelle morini-bosc que ce relooking se
sont pas vus on va faire comme ça ils
vont directement à pour voir comment ils
ont été relookées on va parler de cette
émission dans un instant on va te dire
tout de suite la première relooké c'est
isabelle
sûrement plus
alors j'ai pensé à tous nos jeunes et on
peut avoir une photo déjà belle s'il
vous plaît sur ps qu'on peut avoir une
photo d'isabelle morini-bosc quand elle
est partie quand elle est partie s'il
vous plaît merci aurélie c'est juste une
petite photo ak des voix là alors ils
sont en train de local et il aurait dû
le cas les avants mais voilà c'est la
régir bien sûr vous les connaissez bien
entendu vous connaissez la personne
alors vous je vous dire vous êtes
magnifiques comme ça vous ne vous êtes
pas dur puis davantage ses cheveux à
l'été la moitié de la salle
alors est ce qu'on la trouve cette photo
c'est alors voilà donc regarder quand
vous étiez avons regardé cette belle
comme ça aussi
et là c'est complètement autre chose ils
vous ont mis des melons mais à mon avis
deux paires melon alors attention vous
ne vous êtes pas vu l'allemand isabelle
morini bosc
oui c'est salma hayek oui c'est avec tes
conneries plus tôt alors vous êtes
magnifique je vous le dis vous allez
avoir un choc mais mettez vous bien
devant le miroir attention serait mieux
si je les prenais grecque non non non
voilà attention
ayant bien
jacques dont +12 à des niveaux plus je
pense que je vais faire nourrir ça vous
plaît ou pas les saints non d'accord le
reste oui à tout le reste oui la coupe
ettu la paix rue je rêve d'avoir des
cheveux longs et lisses donc moi la
perruque ma passion salon milieu de
semaine prochaine sur la sauce pas
d'accord merci isabelle maury moi quelle
aventure
photo gilles verdez vous donner c'est
gilles verdez dans volvo c'est ça alors
on va avoir une photo de gilles verdez
normalement mais voilà c'est touche pas
à mon poste gibert d'elle donc on va
faire rentrer d'abord gilles verdez
voilà puisque ont résulté
ashton moi ça va super bien on dirait on
dirait on dirait qu'il va animer silence
ça pousse
gilles verdez vous le connaissez dans la
loire c'est ça et mes gilles vous ne
vous êtes pas vu là bas non non non non
mais sans rigoler mais vous est énorme
alors comme ça c'est magnifique ce
réveil bah ouais ça me va bien et
attention
gilles verdez
mes parents
c
ah non c'est rien c'est un miroir pour
l'acheter opus tout à l'heure c'est vrai
c'est pas mal pas mal du tout quoi ça
vous fait pour y être comme ça on
croyait que tu rates où ça peut lui
plaire ah non bon d'accord elle aime pas
du tout ça ah non je pense pas bon bah
très bien gilles verdez rester avec nous
bravo bravo bravo styliste à charlotte
et toute l'équipe tout faire
agnès charlotte voilà tous à tous ceux
qui ont fait le stylisme chloé
exactement et il ya les lignes roma qui
doit venir ça y est nous aurons fait ses
mouchoirs
exactement